[Music]
careful kids
electricity can have shocking results
stop drop catch you later
always watch out for cobra whatever you
say lady james
whoa snake ice it looks like snake eyes
has something to say
snake eyes doesn't talk actually i'm
henry gould
henry i play snake eyes in the new movie
wait you made a snake eyes movie without
us no just without you guys
that hurts call your jacks duke see kids
sometimes friends need time apart to
explore what makes them mysterious ninja
assassins
friends understand giving each other
space what about enemies
[Music]
henry golding is a badass i'm snake eyes
now you know
[Applause]
joe
[Applause]
wants to see you in trouble someone is
this man betrayed our trust
you've saved my life we are going home
i don't have a home not yours
mine i can't change your past
but i can't offer you a purpose
for 600 years our
[Music]
all right what do i have to do
you'll gain access to our knowledge and
our power
[Music]
cobra is coming that's cobra a shadow
organization devoted to global
revolution
i've been following you for some time do
i know you i know you
snake eyes
join us
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you